Quantum computing to change everything
and it could represent a fundamental
change from the way we process
information today. Plus it could enable
us to understand our world in new and
different ways potentially solving
previously intractable problems. So think
about the implications, right. Experts are
already looking into ways quantum
computing could be used in areas like
financial services, chemistry, artificial
intelligence, and like so many recent
advancements in technology. Quantum
computers could change how we approach
cybersecurity. We're considering how
quantum could disrupt the very basis of
today's encryption methods and impact
cryptography standards, and I know it can
be pretty easy to think I've got plenty
of time quantum computing is years from
mature raishin, but that's only partially
true. Yes,
quantum computers are in the early
stages of development, but the reality is
the time to prepare was yesterday
because encrypted data stolen today
could eventually be in the hands of
cyber attackers wielding more advanced
quantum computers tomorrow, but
fortunately there's help. Researchers are
now developing alternative methods
designed to protect data as quantum
computing progresses and these new
methods could really change the way we
think about an approach cybersecurity.
We're gaining these new understandings
of how to apply quantum safe
cryptography to help protect systems and
data against current and future attacks
it's honestly never too early to prepare
companies today can start building an
understanding of the potential impact to
their sensitive data and they can
educate their security teams on quantum
computing and quantum safe cryptography.
Now is the time to start making your
security strategy quantum ready.